We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. How to make a concrete stylus. Take a large nail.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加利福尼亚州乃至全球范围内合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命的一部分。请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是“99%看不见”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。如何制作混凝土手写笔。拿一颗大钉子。
Heat the tip red hot in a blue gas flame. Drop it in ice water. Now it will resist abrasion as it cuts through the sand, cement, and rock particles in concrete not yet hardened. From the abstract to the concrete, signed, a friend. I first found Nico by staring at the sidewalks. Delphine Visual is a journalist from San Francisco. One of my favorite things was always to kind of get lost in San Francisco and stare at things that I normally might have looked past. And then I saw his name written in the sidewalk.
在蓝色气焊火焰中将笔尖加热至通红。把它扔进冰水中。现在它在切割混凝土中尚未硬化的沙子、水泥和岩石颗粒时，将能抵抗磨损。从抽象到具体，署名，一位朋友。我最初是通过盯着人行道发现尼科的。德尔芬·维吉尔是来自旧金山的记者。我最喜欢的事情之一就是总是迷失在旧金山，盯着那些我平时可能会忽视的东西。然后我看到他的名字写在人行道上。
Nico. And I thought it was interesting. And then a block then I saw his name written in the sidewalk. RUCO. And I thought it was interesting. And then a block later, I found his name again. RUCO. I turned a corner through Chinatown into North Beach, and I found another one. I would find them not just in North Beach, but Chinatown, Russian Hill, Telegraph Hill.
尼科。我当时觉得这很有趣。然后过了一个街区，我又看到他的名字写在人行道上。RUCO。我觉得这很有趣。然后又过了一个街区，我又找到了他的名字。RUCO。我拐过一个弯，穿过中国城来到北滩，又找到了一个。我发现它们不仅在北滩，还在中国城、俄罗斯山、电报山。
They would be references to the street name. Niko and Barbara, Niko and Night. Or Niko downtown. And then the personality, I mean, it was really coy. It was like, Niko was here, Niko gets it all. Niko concrete compulsive. And I remember once of me was really coy. It was like, Nico was here, Nico gets it all. Nico concrete compulsive. And I remember once, I was just saying to myself,
这些将是对街道名称的引用。尼科和巴巴拉，尼科和夜晚。或者市中心的尼科。然后是他的个性，我的意思是，它真的很腼腆。就像是，尼科来过这里，尼科拥有一切。尼科混凝土强迫症。我记得有一次，我的性格真的很腼腆。就像是，尼科来过这里，尼科拥有一切。尼科混凝土强迫症。我还记得有一次，我对自己说，
damn, Nico is everywhere. And then I looked down and it said, Nico is everywhere. I felt like a duty. And I remember thinking that, this is my duty to write this story. And then coincidentally, I'd run across a clue that said, Nico on duty. So Delphine decided to track Nico down.
该死，尼科无处不在。然后我低头一看，上面写着：尼科无处不在。我觉得这是一种责任。我记得当时想，写下这个故事是我的责任。然后巧合的是，我遇到了一条线索，上面写着：尼科在值班。于是德尔芬决定追踪尼科。
You know, I wanted to know, was this guy alive? Why did he do it? It was the first time I'd ever felt like I was the one paying attention in class. The tag started in 1967. Because I saw the date 1967, I figured, well, he must have been about, I don't know, 12 years old. In some ways, I got to watch him grow up
你知道，我想知道，这家伙还活着吗？他为什么这么做？这是我有生以来第一次觉得自己是班上那个注意力集中听讲的人。这个涂鸦标签始于 1967 年。因为我看到了 1967 这个日期，我想，好吧，他当时大概，我不知道，12 岁左右。在某种程度上，我看着他长大，
because I felt like his personality kind of got a little more bolder through the years. Earlier stuff made me just say Nico. And later on, he would call himself Nico concrete artist. I figured he went to school in the neighborhood, so I went to the high school Galileo and I went to Francisco Middle School.
因为我觉得他的个性这些年来变得稍微更大胆了一些。早期的作品只让我说尼科。后来，他自称为尼科混凝土艺术家。我想他是在附近的学校上学，所以我去了伽利略高中，也去了弗朗西斯科初中。
And so I would start photocopying your book pictures from the 60s and 70s. And I would base this on guys who look like they just had that kind of artful dodger look in their eye. What changed family that was? And this investigation went on through years of dead ends, knocking on stranger stores and getting nowhere. And if right now you're thinking, I love this Nico kid, he's my hero too.
所以我开始复印你 60 年代和 70 年代的书本照片。我将根据那些看起来眼中带有那种机灵鬼外观的家伙来进行筛选。那是怎样的一个改变家庭的过程呢？这项调查经历了多年的死胡同，敲陌生人的门却一无所获。如果你现在想的是，我喜欢这个叫尼科的小家伙，他也是我的英雄，
Wait for it. Here it comes. I was by the North Beach playground. I believe it was rainy day and rainy days were always the best days to read the concrete because it washed away a lot of the dirt and you could read things that on other days you probably couldn't see. And I saw this etching that was the longest that I'd ever seen. It took up an entire sidewalk block. It was like a paragraph. And at first I thought, now it can't be him. I think it said... America is a great country built by the white man, home by the Jews, ruined by the...
等等。它来了。我在北滩游乐场附近。我记得那天在下雨，下雨天总是阅读混凝土的最佳日子，因为它冲走了很多污垢，你可以读到平时可能看不到的东西。我看到了这个蚀刻，这是我见过最长的一个。它占据了整个人行道街区。就像一个段落。起初我想，不，这不可能是他。我想上面写着……美国是一个伟大的国家，由白人建造，犹太人居住，却被……毁了。
And then the first word began with an end, but I can't actually say for sure, I mean, I can presume what it said, and you probably can too. But those letters were actually washed away from foot traffic. And then I'd found quite a few others, and it was, you know, I'm talking 10, 15, 20. Oh, man. As far as I could tell from the handwriting, it was Nico. I didn't want to believe it,
然后第一个词以 n 开头，但我其实不能确定地说，我的意思是，我可以推测它说的是什么，你可能也能。但那些字实际上已经被行人的脚步声冲刷掉了。然后我发现了相当多其他的，你知道的，我说的是 10 个、15 个、20 个。天哪。据我从笔迹判断，那是尼科。我不想相信，
because it didn't go with, you know, what I identified with. I mean, to some extent, I wanted to identify as the kind of loner kid in the city too. And this happened right before I finally found him. One of the leads finally panned out. And after a long email courtship, Delphine Vigil grabbed his notebook and microcoset recorder and met Nico.
因为它与我所认同的并不相符。我的意思是，在某种程度上，我也想将自己认同为城市里的那种孤独小孩。而这一切发生在我终于找到他之前不久。其中一条线索终于有了结果。在长期的电子邮件追求之后，德尔芬·维吉尔抓起她的笔记本和微型录音机，见到了尼科。
How did you never get caught? Did I like to tie your shoes? Did I like you tying your shoes? It was a trick of a worker, but did I like you drop something? Met Nico. Nico described all the places he tagged in detail, and Delphine believes that the vast majority of them are from this one guy. My thoughts were that if I do this really deep and do it right, this stuff will last way into the future and it'll be like the concrete will be all washed away with the pebbles poking up my nails so later. It's kind of like any story you get into when you have a hunch about it.
你怎么从来没被抓住？我喜欢系鞋带吗？我喜欢你系鞋带吗？那是工人的把戏，但我喜欢你掉东西吗？见到了尼科。尼科详细描述了他贴标签的所有地方，德尔芬认为绝大多数都是出自这一个人。我的想法是，如果我深入研究并且做得对，这些东西会一直持续到未来，就像混凝土会被冲刷干净，卵石会从我的指甲里露出来一样。这有点像你偶然有预感的任何故事。
A lot of it was very close to what I had imagined and a lot of it was completely different. He did have a very artful dodger lifestyle. His father was out of the picture, and he had a very bohemian upbringing with kind of like a real carefree parenting style. He was just this kid who was sort of in some ways forgotten. And after a few meetings, Delphine finally found the opportunity to ask the hard questions.
很多事情与我所想象的非常接近，而很多事情则完全不同。他确实有一种机灵鬼式的生活方式。他的父亲不在他的生活中，他有着非常波西米亚式的成长经历，父母的养育方式非常无忧无虑。他只是那种在某些方面被遗忘了的孩子。在几次会面之后，德尔芬终于找到了提出尖锐问题的机会。
I would see a ban all non-white immigration over by the Stockton Tunnel and then I'd see it over on Russian Hill. There's how about white race consciousness keeping America white? About 12 or 13 of them in the same block of cement. I'd also saw the name Nico. And you let's jump ahead. You probably want to know, did I write that stuff? Well, I'll be straight up honest with you.
我会在斯托克顿隧道附近看到一条“禁止所有非白人移民”的标语，然后在俄罗斯山上也会看到。比如“白人种族意识，保持美国纯洁”怎么样？同一块水泥里大约有 12 到 13 个这样的标语。我还看到了尼科这个名字。让我们快进一下。你可能想知道，那些东西是我写的吗？好吧，我会对你直言不讳的。
I think you did. I can pick out about 15 to 20 that seemed to me would be the same guy who did Nico who would be you. But if I'm wrong, he's the deal. When I was a kid growing up in the city, I'm talking a little kid. The Sunday we would go to March in Oakland for some rights for a peace march. On Monday I'd go to school and I'd get the **** kicked out of me by the very people that we were all Beautifully trying to help. I mean this sounds absurd now But it was all in my mind. It was all put together. Well, if you get right down to it How is the boring suburban kid rebellion to their parents? They go to the opposite extreme. Yeah Believe in right, but I repent
我想你写了。我能挑出大约 15 到 20 个，在我看来它们似乎是同一个做尼科的人干的，那个人就是你。但如果我错了，这就是交易。当我还是个在这个城市里长大的孩子时，我是说一个小孩子。星期天我们会去奥克兰游行，为一些权利进行和平游行。星期一我去上学，结果被我们试图美丽地帮助的那些人狠狠地揍了一顿。我的意思是这现在听起来很荒谬，但它全在我的脑海里。这一切都是拼凑起来的。好吧，如果你归根结底的话，无聊的郊区孩子对父母的反叛是怎么样的？他们走向极端的反面。是的，相信正义，但我忏悔
Totally understand. I'm a hardcore green activist now, man Have some more cheap things And that explanation would sit better if the past wasn't written in concrete. I've not written my name, but I've written his name in wet concrete. In fact, that was the first line I wrote for the story it was in the sidewalk.
完全理解。我现在是一个铁杆绿色激进分子，伙计。再来点便宜的东西吧。如果过去不是用混凝土写成的，那种解释会更容易让人接受。我没有写下我的名字，但我把他的名字写在了湿混凝土里。事实上，那是我为这个故事写的第一行，它在人行道上。
Gwaka Montgomery Street, toward the Union Street steps, and make a right at Green Street, and right there, unless someone's double parked on top of it, it should still say, I found Nico. I found Nico. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Stephanie Fu and me Roman Mars.
沿着蒙哥马利街向尤宁街阶梯方向走，在格林街右转，就在那里，除非有人双排停车停在它上面，否则它应该仍然写着：我找到了尼科。我找到了尼科。“99%看不见”本周由斯蒂芬妮·傅和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。
A different version of the story was originally broadcast on the public radio program Snap Judgment, which I know you already subscribed to, but if you don't, do yourself a favor, go find it in the iTunes and subscribe, you will love it. This program is made possible with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW, the American Institute of Architects, San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture and Design to find out more, including how you can get your hands on delphined vigils, self-published chatbook, all about the Nico story with beautiful illustrations and way
该故事的不同版本最初在公共广播节目《瞬间裁决》上播出，我知道你已经订阅了，但如果没有，帮自己一个忙，去 iTunes 上找并订阅，你会喜欢它的。本程序由 Lunar 提供支持，用创造力带来改变。这是 KALW、美国建筑师学会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心的项目，了解更多信息，包括如何获取德尔芬·维吉尔自出版的关于尼科故事的小册子，其中包含精美的插图以及比我在这里能讲的更多的细节，请访问我们的网站。网址是 99%invisible.org。这个剧集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
more detail than I can go and do here, go to our website. It's 99%invisible.org. you you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你还没有对此剧集的评论。点击文本记录中的任意句子发表评论。